This Friday chit-chat is presented by Macy's. When you look good, you feel unstoppable, and Macy's is the destination to discover fashion that will help you show up as your best. Shop in store or at Macy's.com. You know, how when you look good, you feel unstoppable? Yeah. Well, that's what you need this time of year. And Macy's makes it easy to treat yourself to fashion that helps you show up as your best self. You know, January is the time of New Year's resolutions and restart.
这个周五的闲聊环节由梅西百货（Macy's）为您呈现。当你外表光鲜时，你会感到势不可挡，而梅西百货就是你寻找时尚的绝佳去处，它能帮你展现出最完美的自己。欢迎到店选购或登录Macy's.com。你知道那种外表光鲜、感觉势不可挡的状态吗？没错。嗯，这就是你在一年中的这个时候所需要的。梅西百货让你轻松犒赏自己，用时尚帮你展现出最好的状态。你知道的，一月份就是新年决心和重新开始的月份。
and re-energizing yourself. And I was just re-watching with my family, the Boys and Girls episode, and Jan has a quote where she says, dress for the job you want, not the job you have. Oh. Because, you know,
以及重塑自干劲。我最近正和家人重看《办公室》里“男孩女孩”那一集，简有一句台词说，穿出你向往的工作所需要的服装，而不是你目前的工作所拥有的服装。哦。因为，你知道，
you add that piece to your wardrobe and suddenly you get a new confidence. You become a new person. Yeah. Well, I can tell you this. Macy's has everything you need for that power outfit. You know I had to do
当你为衣橱添置了这件衣服时，你突然间就获得了一种新的自信。你变成了一个崭新的人。是的。嗯，我可以告诉你这一点。梅西百货拥有你打造那种气场穿搭所需的一切。你知道我不得不为
all this press for the cookbook. I went to Macy's, and I got myself some sharp-looking outfits so I could go on all these talk shows and do everything. You looked really cute. Thank you. Macy's makes it easy to treat yourself to fashion that helps you show up as your best, whether that's crushing it at work or taking that well-deserved getaway. Shop now at Macy's.com or in store. Oh, happy Friday. Happy Friday, chit-chat, everyone, our first one of 2026. Yeah. You know, we've been talking a lot on the
这本烹饪书做所有的宣传采访。我去了梅西百货，给自己买了几套看起来很精神的衣服，这样我就可以去上所有这些脱口秀节目并完成各项工作了。你看起来真的很可爱。谢谢你。梅西百货让你轻松犒赏自己，用时尚帮你展现最佳状态，无论是工作上大显身手，还是进行一次渴望已久的度假。现在就登录 Macy's.com 或到店选购吧。哦，周五快乐。大家周五闲聊快乐，这是我们2026年的第一期。是的。你知道，我们在播客里一直在
pod about our resolutions, our shared resolution this year, Angela. Yeah, we have a BFF shared resolution to get off the hamster wheel. And to do one thing at a time. Yeah. And I have another one. What's that? They're all just like permeations of the same thing. Okay.
聊我们的决心，我们今年的共同决心，安杰拉。是的，我们有一个闺蜜间的共同决心，那就是摆脱仓鼠式的盲目循环。并且一次只做一件事。是的。我还有另一个。是什么？它们其实都是同一件事的不同变体。好吧。
Mine was let's get off the hamster wheel. Yes. What are you bringing at me? I'm bringing little fixes, little wins. Ooh, I like that. So like not coming in hot with giant goals and like major plans. Yeah. Little things.
我的是让我们摆脱仓鼠式的循环。没错。你有什么新主意？我带来了一些小改进、小小的胜利。哦，我喜欢这个。也就是说，不要带着巨大的目标和宏伟的计划气势汹汹地入场。是的。一些小事。
Little adjustments. Little things. But that like make things run smoother. I did this years ago, and I love it. Okay, here's my little fix of the week. Okay. This is my example. My hand towels in my guest bathroom have been dingy for a while.
一些小调整。一些小事。但能让事情运转得更顺畅。我多年前就这样做了，而且我很喜欢。好吧，这是我本周的小改进。好吧。这就是我的例子。我客房浴室里的擦手巾已经发旧一段时间了。
I just haven't replaced them. Right. Because who has the time? Who has the time? And it's not a big deal, you know? But when we had our Christmas party, at Christmas, I was like, oh, I got to put out the dingy hand towels again because I never fixed to that. So I fixed it. You got new hand towels.
我只是没去换它们。对啊。因为谁有那个时间呢？谁有那个时间？而且这也不是什么大不了的事，对吧？但当我们开圣诞派对时，在圣诞节那天，我在想，哦，我又得把那些发旧的擦手巾拿出来了，因为我一直没去处理这事。所以我把它解决了。你买了新擦手巾。
I love them. That's the thing. They're just green striped towels. They're not a big deal. But I like them. And I looked at the little tag, and then I found the website where I got them years ago. And I ordered two new ones, and they just arrived, and they're making me very happy. They're fresh towels.
我很喜欢它们。就是这样。它们只是绿条纹的毛巾。没什么大不了的。但我很喜欢。我看了看小标签，然后找到了我多年前买它们的网站。我订了两条新的，它们刚刚送到，这让我非常开心。它们是崭新的毛巾。
Fresh. Fresh. But I did tell my family, guys, that fresh ones are for the guests. We're going to keep using the tingey ones. But if someone comes over. Put the nice ones out. I'm putting the nice ones out. I have one.
崭新的。崭新的。不过我确实告诉我的家人，伙计们，新毛巾是给客人用的。我们要继续用那些发旧的。但如果有客人来。把漂亮的毛巾拿出来。我把漂亮的毛巾拿出来了。我有一个。
Okay. A little fix for a big win. Okay, you know the thing that holds a toilet paper and you have to pull it back and there's a spring. Yeah. So whenever you have to change your toilet paper, you got to do the spring. Which feels like such a big effort, which is why people always just set it on top. Well, ours, I don't know who made our springy thing, but when you pull it back, the freaking thing like springs out. Oh, yeah.
好吧。一个带来巨大胜利的小改进。好吧，你知道那个挂卫生纸的杆子，你得把它往回拉，里面有一个弹簧。对。所以每当你要换卫生纸时，你都得对付那个弹簧。这感觉像是一项巨大的工程，这就是为什么人们总是直接把它放在上面。好吧，我们的那个，我不知道是谁造了我们这个带弹簧的东西，但是当你把它拉回来时，那个该死的东西就会弹出来。哦，对。
And then I'm like on the ground. I'm getting the spiral thing. I'm putting it back in. I'm putting the thing back together. Yes. Then I'm getting the toilet paper. Yes. So the other day, it sprung out and it like snapped my finger.
然后我就趴在地上了。我在找那个螺旋的东西。我把它安回去。我把那东西重新组装好。是的。然后我才拿到卫生纸。是的。所以有一天，它弹了出来，还差点夹到我的手指。
Like it, I don't even know how I did it, but it like kind of hit, you know when you hit your fingernail at an angle, then it feels like a nail bed bruise. Where's the win in this story? It's coming. Okay. But have you ever done? Yes, of course. Yes.
就像是，我甚至不知道我是怎么弄的，但它差不多是撞到了，你知道当你从某个角度撞到指甲时，就会感觉像甲床淤青了一样。这个故事里的胜利在哪里？快到了。好吧。但你有没有过这种经历？有，当然有。是的。
So then your fingernail hurts. I was like, to hell with these things. I'm done. And I was like, Josh, there's a lot. There's got to be a better solution. There's got to be a better way. And he found the, now look, there's some toilet paper holders that's just a hook and you just slide it on. Yeah.
所以你的指甲就会痛。我当时想，见鬼去吧，我受够这些东西了。我受够了。我就说，乔希，这有很多。一定有更好的解决办法。一定有更好的方法。然后他找到了，现在听着，有些卫生纸架只是一个钩子，你直接把纸滑上去就行了。对。
He found one that's like a little arm that goes, it just lifts up. You put the roll on and it just clicks back down. Oh. So guess who has those in all the bathrooms minus one. We didn't count them up enough. But yeah, we've got them in almost every bathroom now. Wow. I know. No more springy thing. I'm done with the springy thing. Gosh, that is big win.
他找到了那种像一个小臂一样的，它只要提起来。你把纸卷套上去，然后它就啪嗒一声合下去。哦。所以你猜谁在除了一个之外的所有浴室里都装了这种？我们数得不够多。但是，是的，我们现在几乎每个浴室都有了。哇。我知道。再也没有弹簧玩意儿了。我受够弹簧玩意儿了。天哪，那真是一场巨大的胜利。
I can't tell you how much happier I am. Yes, now we're out of toilet paper. I'm like, I don't have to deal with the spring anymore. Amazing. Well, done. So I want to look for these like little things and the effort that it took. It was minimal. It was minimal. Because that's all I got. I got minimal effort to make little fixes. Josh found them at the hardware store. We just swapped them out. The other ones. Put the other ones in. I love it. All right. Well, listen. For this Friday chit-chat, we are going to you all. We've got a chit-chat suggestion from Freya in Phoenixville, Pennsylvania. What is Freya going to ask us?
我无法形容我有多开心。是的，现在我们用完卫生纸了。我在想，我再也不用跟弹簧打交道了。太棒了。干得好。所以我想寻找这些小事情以及它所需要的努力。那是微乎其微的。那是微乎其微的。因为这就是我所有的精力。我只需要付出微乎其微的努力就能做点小改进。乔希在五金店找到它们的。我们只是把它们换掉了。其他的。把其他的换上。我很喜欢。好了。那么，听着。对于今天的周五闲聊，我们要向大家发出邀请。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州菲尼克斯维尔的弗雷娅的闲聊建议。弗雷娅要问我们什么呢？
I don't know. Let's hear it. Let's hear it. Hi, office ladies. My name is Freya, and I am from Phoenixville, Pennsylvania. And I love your podcast. I listen to it every day when I visit my patients. I'm a home health nurse, so I drive a lot. and my question is what is your ideal date or like an ideal romantic date with your significant others
我不知道。我们听听看。我们听听看。嗨，办公室女士们。我叫弗雷娅，我来自宾夕法尼亚州菲尼克斯维尔。我非常喜欢你们的播客。我每次去探望病人的路上都会听。我是一名居家保健护士，所以我经常开车。而我的问题是，你们理想中的约会是什么样的，或者说和你们的另一半进行一次理想的浪漫约会是怎样的？
and Cassie and Sam please answer this as well thank you I love you guys bye oh okay yes okay I remember this I remember choosing this one and I had said something at dinner I said oh I'm going to be sharing on the podcast what my ideal date is with my significant other. I did the same with Josh, because I was like, you have to be part of this answer. Well, it's funny, my daughter piped up and she said, I know what it is. Oh, yeah? Movie Monday. Oh, you do.
凯西和萨姆请也回答一下，谢谢你们，我爱你们，拜拜。哦，好的，好。我记得这个。我记得选了这个，我当时在晚餐时说过一些话，我说，哦，我将在播客上分享我和另一半理想中的约会是什么样的。我对乔希也做了同样的事，因为我想，你必须成为这个答案的一部分。嗯，有趣的是，我女儿突然插话了，她说，我知道那是什么。哦，是吗？电影星期一。哦，你知道的。
You guys love to go to a movie together. You do like a little matinee thing. We do a matinee movie Monday. This was a thing we started a few months ago, and we love it. We go during the day. I mean, listen, we both work from home, primarily. So we have that kind of flexibility. Sure.
你们俩喜欢一起去看电影。你们会搞一个小场日场电影之类的。我们有个日场电影星期一。这是我们几个月前开始的一个活动，我们非常喜欢。我们在白天去看。我的意思是，听吧，我们基本上都在家工作。所以我们有那种灵活性。当然。
But the kids are at school, so we don't have to get a sitter. Right. And we carve out a couple hours on a Monday. And maybe we'll go to lunch and then see the movie or maybe we'll see the movie. And then the kids will meet us up at the mall where we see movies for dinner. And we'll have dinner in the food court. And it's fun. They're getting used to.
但孩子们在上学，所以我们不需要找保姆。对。我们在周一腾出几个小时。也许我们会去吃午饭，然后看电影，或者也许我们先看电影。然后孩子们会在我们看电影的商场和我们汇合吃晚饭。我们会在美食广场吃晚饭。这很有趣。他们也习惯了。
They're like, oh, dinner in the food court on Monday because mom and dad did movie Monday. I love a food court. Well, because everybody can get what they want. Everyone wins. Everyone gets what they want. Exactly. Okay, well, I was actually talking to Josh at breakfast about this. I was like, we're going to do this question about an ideal date.
他们会想，哦，周一在美食广场吃晚饭，因为爸爸妈妈去过电影星期一了。我很喜欢美食广场。嗯，因为每个人都能买到自己想要的东西。皆大欢喜。每个人都能得到他们想要的。没错。好吧，其实我在吃早餐时跟乔希聊过这个。我说，我们要讨论这个关于理想约会的问题。
And he was like, well, we know what that is. And we just, we do. So here it is. We love, like, this is in an ideal world where we have like maybe a weekend away, you know, this is our favorite thing. Where we get up in the morning and we go for a hike or some kind of nature walk, like some big, like hike. But you're out in the fresh. share. We're out in nature. It's like somewhere where there's lots of green and trees and maybe some water, like get out there, right? And then we would then stop off some little spot local for lunch,
然后他说，好吧，我们知道那是什么。而且我们就是，我们确实如此。所以它是这样的。我们喜欢，就像，这是一个理想的世界，我们可能有周末外出，你知道，这是我们最喜欢的事情。我们早上起床去远足或进行某种自然漫步，比如某种大型远足。但你置身于新鲜空气中。我们置身于大自然中。就像是有很多绿色植物、树木、可能还有水的地方，去户外，对吧？然后我们会在某个当地的小地方停下来吃午饭，
you know, and just kind of explore whatever little town we found. And then, you know, then it's like an afternoon in the hotel because nobody's tired. You're not too full. And then maybe it's just like, like just picking some random movie and being cozy and watching a movie and then lights out by like 9 o'clock. I mean, that sounds amazing as well. Yeah. I think the thing I love about our little movie Mondays is they make me feel kind of like we're back in our young dating lives again because, you know, when you're... You're going to the movie. Yeah. I mean, we did that all the time and we're such movie buffs and we love to talk about the characters and the plot afterwards. And but also like, I don't know, being out in the day like that, it just feels like young and spontaneous and special. And clearly it's working for us because our daughter was like, you guys love your movie Mondays. Yeah.
你知道的，只是探索我们发现的任何小镇。然后，你知道，接下来就像是在酒店度过一个下午，因为没有人会累。你也不会吃得太饱。然后也许就是，就像是随便挑一部电影，舒舒服服地看电影，然后大概9点钟就熄灯睡觉。我的天，听起来也很棒。是的。我想我最喜欢我们的小电影星期一的地方在于，它们让我感觉仿佛回到了我们年轻约会的时光，因为，你知道，当你......你要去看电影。是的。我的意思是，我们以前经常那样做，我们是不折不扣的影迷，我们喜欢事后讨论角色和剧情。但同时，就像，我不知道，在白天那样外出，感觉既年轻、随性又特别。显然这很管用，因为我女儿说，你们俩太喜欢你们的电影星期一了。是的。
And we do. I think that's great. And when we can't get out of town, we just try to go for a walk. Just like a neighborhood walk makes me happy. And we like talk and he is so patient. He stops while I take a picture of a flower that I, you know, it could be the same patch of flowers I walk past all. the time, but I'm like, oh, that one's blooming. I should take a picture of it. Can I say something else I love doing with Lee?
而且我们的确很喜欢。我觉得这很棒。当无法离开小镇时，我们就会尽量去散步。就像在社区散步就能让我开心。我们会聊天，而且他非常有耐心。当我停下来给一朵花拍照时，他会等着我，你知道的，这可能是我一直走过的那片花丛，但我想，哦，那朵正在盛开呢。我应该拍张照。我能说另一件我喜欢和李一起做的事吗？
What? That I consider, like, sometimes this is like a date. I love going grocery shopping with him. Oh, yeah. Because we used to do that. Again, like, before we had kids, before we got so busy, you know, now we have to divide and conquer. Like, there's, if somebody's grocery shopping, the other person's doing laundry. Like, we can't do that together. But, oh, my gosh, every once in a while, I love to do like those. Erin Day.
什么？我有时认为这就像是一场约会。我喜欢跟他一起去杂货店买东西。哦，对。因为我们以前经常那样。同样地，在有了孩子之前，在我们变得那么忙碌之前，你知道，现在我们不得不分工合作。比如，如果有人去买杂货，另一个人就在洗衣服。我们没法一起做那些事。但是，天哪，偶尔我真的很喜欢那种......零碎差事日。
I get very excited. Aaron Day. Listen, we're going to drop some things off at the cleaners. Then we're going to stop by and, you know, maybe finally get that rain gauge I've been wanting. Yes. Sometimes our married dating is doing chores together or errands together, but we're in the car alone. Yeah. And then we go grocery shop. And then we come home and make a meal together. Like those moments, I love that. Yeah, me too. Because usually at this time, with the kids, the age they are, everybody's always going in different directions. So busy. I know. So to do something together, I love it. My mom will say, I'll tell her about our day. She'll be like, y'all are so busy. Because we have kids doing all these different activities. This is the busy time. It's the busy time. All right. Well, Sam, Cassie, are you willing to share? Yeah. All right. I'm a big fan of just wasting time with the other person. Oh, yeah. On New Year's Day, my girlfriend, Stephanie was in town and we watched all three Lord of the Rings, extended versions. It took 12 hours, I think. Yeah.
我非常兴奋。差事日。听着，我们要把一些东西送到干洗店。然后我们要顺便去，你知道，也许终于买下那个我一直想要的雨量计。没错。有时我们的夫妻约会是一起做家务或一起跑腿，但我们独自待在车里。对。然后我们去买杂货。然后我们回家一起做一顿饭。像这样的时刻，我太喜欢了。是的，我也是。因为通常在这个时候，随着孩子们长到现在的年纪，每个人总是往不同的方向奔波。太忙了。我知道。所以能一起做点事，我太喜欢了。我妈妈会说，我会跟她聊起我们的日子。她会说，你们可真忙啊。因为我们有孩子们在做各种不同的活动。这是忙碌的时期。这是忙碌的时期。好吧。那么，萨姆，凯西，你们愿意分享吗？好啊。好吧。我非常喜欢和另一个人一起浪费时间。哦，是的。在元旦那天，我女朋友斯蒂芬妮来镇上了，我们看完了《指环王》三部曲的所有加长版。我想花了12个小时吧。对。
Amazing. That's the best. We fell asleep during it. We paused it and got up and went for walks. And just like it took 12 or like 20 hours to watch 11 hours of movies. But it was great. It's just nowhere to be. No set schedule.
太棒了。那是最好的。我们在看的时候睡着了。我们暂停了，然后起来去散步。就像是花了12个小时或者说20个小时来观看11个小时的电影。但那真的很棒。就是没有地方要去。没有固定的时间表。
Just spending time with someone who loved. That's wonderful. Jinks. Oh my gosh. Cassie? Yeah, I really related to both of you guys talking about movies and afternoon stuff and all that. But yeah, I think my ideal date, like we love to. get up early in the morning and, like, go check out a new coffee spot. Oh, yeah. The L.A. River is really
只是和喜欢的人共度时光。太美妙了。真是心有灵犀。天哪。凯西？是的，我真的很能共情你们俩聊到的电影、下午的活动诸如此类的话题。但是，是的，我觉得我理想中的约会，就像我们喜欢......起个大早，然后去打卡一家新的咖啡店。哦，对。洛杉矶河真的
nice because they have those coffee shops that are always popping up and you can walk up and down the river. And then later in the evening, would love to see, like, an L.A. Sparks game, get good seats and then pick up Taco Bell on the way home. It would still be in bed by night. Magically, yes. Maybe, maybe. Or by 11. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We're all going to bed early. We're all going to bed early. Taco Bell on the way home. I mean, that brings me back. What is your order at Taco Bell? My favorite item, it's called cheesy bean and rice burritos. They're so good.
很棒，因为那里总是有各种新开的咖啡店，你可以在河边散步。然后到了傍晚，很想去看一场，比如洛杉矶火花队的比赛，买到好座位，然后在回家的路上买塔可钟（Taco Bell）。还能在夜里前回到床上。神奇的是，是的。也许，也许吧。或者11点前。是的。是的。是的。我们都要早睡。我们都要早睡。回家的路上吃塔可钟。我的意思是，这让我回想起了过去。你在塔可钟的点单是什么？我最喜欢的单品，叫做芝士豆子米饭卷饼。它们太好吃了。
They're so good and they're only like a dollar. Yeah. It's awesome. Yeah. Oh, my God. I love that. Oh, that question made me so happy. Thank you, Freya.
它们太好吃了，而且只要大约一美元。太棒了。是的。哦，天哪。我太喜欢了。哦，那个问题让我太高兴了。谢谢你，弗雷娅。
All right. Well, our next Friday chit chat comes from Peter R in Chandler, Arizona. And here's what he has to say. Hey, office ladies. This is Peter from Chandler, Arizona. I was calling to see how you guys felt about people that don't put their shopping carts back where they belong. I want to know if you guys lean on the side of, you know, hey, let's give them the benefit
好了。嗯，我们的下一个周五闲聊来自亚利桑那州钱德勒的彼得·R。他是这么说的。嘿，办公室女士们。我是来自钱德勒的彼得。我打电话来是想知道你们对那些不把购物车放回原处的人有什么看法。我想知道你们是倾向于，你知道的，嘿，我们给他们留点余地，
at the doubt. Maybe they were in a rush. Or, you know, maybe do you guys feel like we should shun them socially of some way, you know? I don't know how that would happen, but, or is it something that doesn't even matter because you're putting quarters in your shopping carts. So you don't have to worry about that. Well, you know, this is a very loaded question.
也许他们赶时间。还是说，你知道的，你们觉得我们应该在某种程度上在社交上排斥他们，你知道的？我不知道这怎么会发生，或者说这根本不重要，因为你们把硬币塞进购物车里了。所以你们不用担心这个。好吧，你知道的，这是一个非常有争议的问题。
This is in Mike Scher's book. Remember his book? It's the how to be perfect, the correct answer to every moral question. And Mike talked about this. This is like a litmus test. Oh. I looked it up just now because I wanted to get it right. And it says, in a nutshell, the shopping cart theory of morality states that an individual's
这在迈克·舒尔的书里提到过。还记得他的书吗？就是那本《如何做到完美：每一个道德问题的正确答案》。迈克谈到了这个。这就像是一个试金石。哦。我刚才查了一下，因为我想确保准确无误。上面写着，简而言之，购物车的道德理论表明，个人的
capacity to self-governed depends on whether or not they are the type to return a shopping cart or leave it next to their car or elsewhere. I always return it. I return my shopping cart. Same. Also, I think let's address how you return it to the little cart catty thing. Do you just kind of slam it towards it so it bounces off the side and doesn't really go in? Like you've done it, but you've done it half-assed, as my dad would say.
自我管理能力取决于他们是那种会把购物车归还的人，还是会把它留在车旁或其他地方的人。我总是会归还。我归还我的购物车。我也是。另外，我觉得我们应该讨论一下你是怎么把它塞进那个小购物车集中处的。你是直接把它猛推过去，让它撞到侧面然后根本没有真正推进去吗？就像你做了这件事，但正如我爸爸会说的那样，你只是敷衍了事。
Don't half-ass it. Don't half-ass it. That's something I say to the kids all the time. It's like, yeah, you unload the groceries and like the apples are in the little baggy. Go the extra mile. Finish it. Lady, you know that's our thing. That's our thing.
别敷衍了事。别敷衍了事。这是我经常对孩子们说的话。就像是，对啊，你卸下了杂货，苹果却还在小袋子里。多做一步。把它完成。女士们，你们知道那是我们的口头禅。那是我们的口头禅。
Are either of you familiar with the Instagram account Cartnarks? No! What is this, Sam? It has 1.2 million followers. It's C-A-R-T-N-A-R-C-S. It's a guy who's a fictional parking lot enforcement. He doesn't work for the company. Is he the Dwight Shrews?
你们俩有人熟悉Instagram账号“购物车纠察队”（Cartnarks）吗？没有！这是什么，萨姆？它有120万粉丝。就是C-A-R-T-N-A-R-C-S。这是一个扮演虚构的停车场执法人员的家伙。他不是这家公司雇的。他是个小 Dwight Schrute（《办公室》角色）吗？
Yes, he goes around shaming people who don't put their cars away. He's the deputy sheriff. He has magnets made that he sticks to your car. And when people, like, he has a bag of when people get out of their car angly and throw him off. He just throws two moron. It's great. Oh my God. I'm looking this up right now.
对，他到处去羞辱那些不把购物车收好的人。他就是副警长。他定制了磁铁贴在你的车上。当人们，比如，当人们气冲冲地从车里出来想扔掉他时。他就直接扔过去两个白痴。这太棒了。哦，天哪。我现在正在查这个。
Well, Cassie, Sam, do you return your shopping cart? Every time. Oh, yeah. I get really mad if someone doesn't either. Yeah. You know what? Because you're civilized. You're civilized.
好吧，凯西，萨姆，你们会归还购物车吗？每次都还。哦，对。如果有人不还，我也会真的很生气。对。你知道吗？因为你是个文明人。你是个文明人。
And now, I'm not like, I'm not going to get like hostile or aggressive, but I am going to shoot you a side-eye snark look. But let me ask you this question. So I feel like the, you know, shopping centers, they used to have a lot of cart returns. And I'm noticing I just went grocery shopping recently. There were none. Like, they're getting rid of them to make more parking maybe. So in order to return your shopping cart, you have to walk it all the way back up to the entrance of the store. And I wonder, am I obligated to walk it back up to the store if you've removed all the
而且现在，我不是说，我不会变得充满敌意或具有攻击性，但我确实会给你一个斜眼鄙视的表情。但让我问你们这个问题。所以我觉得，你知道的，购物中心以前有很多购物车回收点。而我注意到我最近刚去买过杂货。一个都没有。比如，为了腾出更多停车位，他们可能把这些都取消了。所以为了归还购物车，你必须一路把它推回商店入口。我在想，如果他们取消了所有的
cart returns, like you've made it more inconvenient for me to do it. I think you are. You're still obligated. Get your steps in. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, it also sounds like in that scenario, they probably don't have the labor to have somebody go out and check every 30 minutes and bring cards back in to.
购物车回收点，导致我做这件事变得更不方便了，我是不是还有义务把它推回商店？我觉得你还是有的。你依然有义务。去赚你的步数吧。对。对。对，听起来在那种情况下，他们可能也没有人手每隔30分钟出去巡视一次并把购物车推回来。
So you think it was like they did layoff. So it's not that they were trying to make more parking spaces, but they were actually like, I don't want to hire someone to collect them. so I'm going to get people to put them up at the entrance for me. Yeah. I mean, that pisses me off. Yeah, me too. That annoys me.
所以你觉得这就像是他们在裁员？所以不是他们在试图腾出更多停车位，而是他们实际上在想，我不想雇人来收集它们，所以我打算让人们帮我把它们送到入口处。对。我的意思是，这真把我气到了。对，我也是。这让我很恼火。
Yeah, that's up there with the self-checkout for me. I don't work here. Oh, I don't mind the self-checkout. I get really excited. No, what are you talking about? No, I like, I love this sound. It's very satisfying, like, beep. It takes me back to being a kid.
对，这对我来说和自助结账差不多。我又不在那上班。哦，我不介意自助结账。我真的很兴奋。不，你在说什么？不，我喜欢，我喜欢这个声音。非常解压，就像，“哔”的一声。这让我想起了小时候。
Like, when you were a kid, didn't you want nothing more than to do the little, like, boop-boop gun? Oh, my gosh. I remember I was so excited when Isabel was little, I got her one of those little mini kitchens, you know. She was so excited. And we would just spend Saturday morning cooking stuff. And then we made a whole grocery store. Me and Isabel and Cade one day spent all day making a fake grocery store.
就像，当你还是个孩子的时候，除了想要玩那个像“嘟嘟”枪的小玩意儿，你是不是什么都不想要？哦，天哪。我记得伊莎贝尔小的时候我超级兴奋，我给她买了一个那种小厨房玩具，你知道的。她当时可兴奋了。然后我们会花一整个星期六早上做饭。后来我们还做了一个完整的杂货店。我和伊莎贝尔还有凯德有一天花了一整天做了一个假杂货店。
We made aisles because we had gotten a Fisher Price little mini register that had the little scanner. Yes. It's so fun to scan it. And then we made Josh and Jack come and shop at our grocery store. it was so fun. We do an elaborate diner with a little register. And our little register has a, what you call it? Microphone.
我们划分了过道，因为我们有一个费雪的小型收银机，带小型扫描仪。是的。扫描起来太好玩了。然后我们让乔希和杰克来我们的杂货店买东西。太好玩了。我们还做了一个精致的小餐馆，带一个小收银机。我们的小收银机有一个，你叫它什么来着？麦克风。
Microphone. I don't know why we need that in our diner, but yeah, same. I love that. Yeah. So anyway, I love a self-checkout, Sam. I'll work for you, okay? If you and I go to the grocery store together, I will do yourself checkout. Sure.
麦克风。我不知道为什么我们在餐馆里需要那个，但是的，一样。我太喜欢了。是的。所以无论如何，我很喜欢自助结账，萨姆。我为你打工，好吗？如果你和我一起去杂货店，我会帮你自助结账。当然。
But I think ultimately, yes. To answer Peter's question, we think you should return the shopping cart. We think you should return the shopping cart. By the way, because this reminded me of Mike Scher's book, I looked up some of the other moral questions that he goes through in his book, and they're so good. Here's some of them. Can I still enjoy great art if it was created by terrible people? Oh. Why bother being good at all when there are no consequences for being bad? Should I punch my friend in the face for no reason? But he says, in parentheses, no. I mean, I guess you just have to say,
但归根结底，是的。为了回答彼得的问题，我们认为你应该归还购物车。我们认为你应该归还购物车。顺便说一句，因为这让我想起了迈克·舒尔的书，我查了一下他在书中探讨的其他一些道德问题，它们实在是太棒了。这里有一些。如果伟大的艺术是由糟糕的人创作的，我还能欣赏它吗？哦。既然做坏事没有后果，为什么还要费劲做好人呢？我应该无缘无故地揍我朋友一拳吗？但他在括号里写着，不。我的意思是，我想你只能说，
say, what is my moral compass? Yes. But in his book, he provides you an answer to all of these questions based on his in-depth study of ancient philosophers. And human behavior? Yes, and he's so smart. I loved this book. It was very funny as well, so this is reminding me of his book, so I'm giving it a plug. Ah. Well, there you go. Those are two of our chit chats. Thank you so much to Freya and Peter for writing in and sending us your audio clips. I really enjoyed those conversations. Yes. Now listen, before we go, we've got some office ladies news, and it's some pretty big office ladies news. We do. It's bittersweet office ladies news because our beloved producer Cassie is moving on. And Cassie, you've meant so much to us, but this is also an exciting time for you.
我的道德指南针是什么？是的。但在他的书中，他根据自己对古代哲学家深入研究，为你所有这些问题提供了一个答案。还有人类行为？是的，而且他太聪明了。我很喜欢这本书。也非常搞笑，所以这让我想起了他的书，所以我在这里安利一下。啊。好吧，这就是我们的两则闲聊。非常感谢弗雷娅和彼得写信并给我们发来音频片段。我真的很享受这些对话。好了。现在听着，在我们离开之前，有一些办公室女士的动态，这是相当重磅的办公室女士动态。确实。这是苦乐参半的办公室女士动态，因为我们挚爱的制片人凯西要开启新征程了。凯西，你对我们意义重大，但这对你来说也是一个激动人心的时刻。
And today is actually her last day in the studio here. We have a few more work days, but this is her last day in the studio with us. Yes. And I guess the day you all are hearing this is actually her last day, the way the episode's going to come out. But gosh, Cassie, we just love you so much. Thanks, guys. It's been an absolute pleasure working with you and Sam for the past five years. And we've had a lot of adventures.
今天实际上是她在演播室的最后一天。我们还有几天的工作日，但这是她在演播室和我们在一起的最后一天。是的。我想你们听到这一集的时候，按节目的播出进度，实际上已经是她的最后一天了。但是天哪，凯西，我们太爱你了。谢谢你们，伙计们。过去五年能和你们以及萨姆一起共事绝对是一段美妙的经历。我们经历了很多冒险。
So I'm very honored to share this chapter with you all. Five years, Cassie. I know. I don't know if people know, but you started as our transcriber way back in our Earwolf days. And you moved to being our producer. I went back to our digital clutter, Cassie, and you started as our producer in November of 2020. Wow. It's a long time.
所以能和大家分享这一篇章我深感荣幸。五年了，凯西。我知道。我不知道大家知不知道，但你最初在我们Earwolf时期的节目里是我们的文字记录员。然后你转成了制片人。凯西，我回去翻看了我们的数字资料，你是在2020年11月开始担任制片人的。哇。时间真长。
But you're ready for some new adventures. Yeah, yeah. It's just time to be challenged in a different way. Yeah. Well, your office ladies family is always going to be here for you. I really hope that you pop up and say, ladies, I got a chit chat. We need to discuss. Yeah, I'm sure I will.
但你已经准备好迎接一些新的冒险了。是的，是的。只是觉得是时候在不同的方面接受挑战了。嗯，你们的办公室女士大家庭永远都会在这里支持你。我真的很希望你会突然出现并说，女士们，我有个闲聊话题。我们需要讨论一下。是的，我确信我会的。
And we'll just be always here for you, Cassie. your office ladies family forever. And we have a few little things for you. We're going to give to you after we say goodbye here. But really, thank you so much for everything you've done. There's so much of your job that is behind the scenes. And you just showed up for us so many times time and time again. So we wish you all the best.
而且我们会永远在这里支持你，凯西。你永远都是办公室女士大家庭的一员。我们有一些小东西要送给你。等我们在这里说完再交给你。但真的，非常感谢你所做的一切。你的工作有很大一部分是在幕后进行的。而且你一次又一次地为我们挺身而出。所以我们祝你一切都好。
Thank you so much. Getting a little emotional here. I know. It's going to be weird not to have your face in the booth moving forward. Sam, no pressure. Yeah. I know. Good luck, Sam.
非常感谢。这里有点情绪化了。我知道。接下来没有你的脸在隔音间里，感觉会很怪的。萨姆，没有压力哦。我知道。祝你好运，萨姆。
I know. Well, the second part of this news is that we've got a new face and a new producer, and we're excited to introduce you to our new senior podcast producer, Matt Beagle. Matt, say hi. Hey, office ladies. Matt, you've been training with Cassie for the last couple of weeks, and you're about to take over. How do you feel?
我知道。嗯，这条动态的第二部分是，我们迎来了新面孔和新制片人，我们很高兴向大家介绍我们的新高级播客制片人马特·比格尔。马特，打个招呼吧。嘿，办公室女士们。马特，你过去几周一直在跟凯西实习，你即将接手了。感觉怎么样？
Are you ready? No, I'm just getting. I'm ready to go. I'm thrilled to be here. really big shoes to fill. Cassie's been amazing, getting me up to speed. And I'm so happy to be here. I can't wait to meet and chat with and hear from Office Ladies Listeners and ready to go.
准备好了吗？不，我开玩笑的。我已经准备好了。我非常兴奋能来到这里。这可是要填补非常巨大的空缺。凯西太棒了，帮我快速上手。我很高兴能来到这里。我已经迫不及待地想要结识办公室女士的听众们、和大家聊天并听到大家的反馈了，随时准备出发。
Yay. Yay. Well, 2026, some really fun new beginnings for all of us. And we love you guys. Office Ladies Listeners, the family and support you've been to us all these years is so meaningful to us. And thank you. Yeah. All right.
耶。耶。好吧，2026年，对我们所有人都充满了一些非常有趣的全新开端。我们爱你们。办公室女士的听众们，你们这些年来给予我们的家庭般的温暖和支持对我们意义非凡，非常感谢。是的。好了。
Happy Friday Chit Chat, everybody. We'll see you next week. That's right. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer
周五闲聊快乐，各位。我们下周见。没错。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audience推出的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安杰拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是凯西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗
and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audience的执行制片人是莉娅·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。